in other videos we introduced ourselves
to the idea of orbitals and these are
various orbitals in their various sub
shells that you could find in various
shells of an atom and in this video
we're going a little bit more practice
with electron configuration in
particular we're going to expose
ourselves to the idea of the Alpha bow
principle now alfe bow comes from german
means the building principle it's a very
useful way of thinking about electron
configurations past calcium let's just
get a little bit warmed up what is the
electron configuration of neon pause
this video and think about it and as a
hint I will give you the periodic table
here all right well neon has an atomic
number of 10 and if we're talking about
a neutral neon atom it's going to have
10 electrons and so the first two will
fill that first shell so we have 1 s 2
and then the next two are going to fill
the 2 s subshell in your second shell so
then you're going to have 2 s 2 and then
we have 6 more electrons to get to 10
and that's now going to fill your 2p
sub-shell
so 2 P 6 and so what's the order of the
sub shells that we just filled
well first we filled 1s then we filled
2s then we filled 2p and you can also
see that in the periodic table of
elements in this first row you're
filling that first shell in this second
row or this second period you are
filling that second shell now what's
going to happen if we were to go to say
argon so if you're going to go to argon
what will that electron configuration
look like pause the video and think
about that well we can use the noble gas
configuration or the noble gas notation
we could say alright we're going to be
building off of neon so we're going to
have the electron configuration of neon
but then we're going to add electrons
into our third shell so from neon we
would then add two electrons into the
three s subshell three s2 and then to
get to 18 electrons we're at 12 right
now we're going to have six more that
are going to be in the three p subshell
so three p6 so on this diagram over here
we went from 2s2 2p2 fill-up neon and
then as we went to argon we go to 3 s 2
3 P now what would be the electron
configuration of calcium pause the video
and think about it
all right well calcium has 20 protons so
a neutral calcium would have 20
electrons so 2 more electrons in argon
so we can build off of argon and where
are those electrons going to go and this
is where the Alpha principle is
interesting there is indeed a 3d
subshell but in the case of calcium
instead of those two electrons being in
the 3d subshell they end up in the 4 s
subshell so calcium's electron
configuration is the same as argon and
instead of it being 3d - here on top of
that it goes straight to 4s - and so
that's why I was drawing this diagram
like this and you'll often see that in
an introductory chemistry class you fail
one ask first
no surprises you're filling in that
first shell then you fill 2s then you
fill 2 P and you filled your second
shell then you go to 3s once again no
surprises then you go to 3p now this is
the surprise and why this alpha diagram
is useful for electron configuration
purposes if you're thinking about
potassium or calcium the extra electrons
are now going to go in the 4 s subshell
so now let's think about what the
electron configuration of scandium would
be pause this video and think about that
well scandium has one more proton than
calcium has 21 protons and if it is
neutral it's also going to have one more
electron relative to a neutral calcium
atom and so it could have a similar
electron configuration so
we could base it off of argon we have
two electrons in the four s subshell
so I'll write for s2 and the Aufbau
principle would describe that and the
Aufbau principle this little diagram
would say alright that other electron is
going to be in the 3d subshell so you do
3d one and this is indeed an accurate
electron configuration for scandium now
the Aufbau principle makes you think
that you're filling 4s first and then
you are starting to fill 3d if you are
actually building up a scandium atom and
that's actually taught in most chemistry
books and in most classes but actually
if people start with the scandium
nucleus that has 18 electrons so that
would have a positive charge when they
add that first electron it actually does
not go to 4s it goes to 3d so this
electron actually gets added first if
you're actually thinking about building
but I don't want to confuse you too much
in this video we're just thinking about
the electron configuration and for that
alfe bow can be very useful now for
electron configuration purposes 3d you
then go to 4p and then use then go to 5s
and that's why you might see this type
of a diagram once again in your
traditional first-year chemistry books
so the big takeaway here is the Alpha
principle that you'll learn this type of
diagram it's useful for electron
configuration and it might be useful to
think about it as you're building these
atoms electron by electron but if you
really want the precise accurate truth
once you get beyond calcium it gets a
little bit more complicated now one
other thing that I want you to
appreciate based on what we just learned
is patterns in the periodic table of
elements
so for which elements are we building
out our s subshell well you could see
that for all of these elements right
over here these first two columns were
building out our s subshell now it looks
like something is missing there is there
something else that builds out our s
subshell well from
at point of view we could actually think
of helium as being right over here
because helium were building out that
one s subshell
and because of that all of these
elements right over here we say that
they are in the s-block now which
elements are building out their p sub
shells well all of these elements right
over here are building out their p sub
shells or have it fully built out and
because of that all of these elements we
call these the p block and these
elements in the middle right over here
scandium is one of them they are called
the D block now one reason why folks
might have called the D block is if you
really imagine the Aufbau principle as
building up atoms it might be tempting
to say oh well we're building in the
fourth row here we're building the three
d subshell or in the fifth row here
we're building the four d subshell now
we now know that that actually isn't
true but from electron configuration
point of view it can appear that way and
so that's why it is called the D block
and I will leave you there